The year 2023 WILL go down in history as the year that the PSOE en bloc
embraced the postulates of puchemon and anvil
makers and making necessity a virtue.
As said,
he granted amnesty for the coup plotters,
validated the pro-independence narrative of democrats and repressors,
accepted the persecution of judges and prosecutors,
broke the equality between Spaniards to give more to those who steal the most,
accepted mediators to humiliate Spain,
accepted linguistic impositions of those who persecute
Spanish in Catalonia and now negotiates 1 next secession
referendum in opaque tables with those who want to break Spain.